okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel and
welcome to my friend
ally
hello thank you for having me yes i know
that whenever we hang out and live
stream that a feminist cries
they hate us
for the dumbest reason ever like if they
were nicer if they were nicer i think
we'd stop talking about them but they're
not they're amazing
anyways so guys today we have we have a
segment okay that we we have come up
with it and it is called the audacity
where we talk about the people that have
the audacity in our comment section this
week
oh there's there's a lot there's a lot
we should talk about the sister wife
email
that was the most audacity that was a
lie
ah audacity
so
did you get the same email i did get the
same email i did can you explain to the
viewers what the email explained
okay guys i know that we
we
me and ally have different views on
cheating than a lot of women
however
that is not an invitation
to ask me to be ali's sister wife
okay
that is not what we meant
um i got an email this week
that was humbly suggesting
that me and ali become sister wives in
nebraska
he said i'd be the perfect sister wife
specifically in nebraska i think he got
the states wrong i mean i live in kansas
but also
you know i think that's a little bit
rude
on his part because
i have a very obvious preference for
white men but pearl seems to be more you
know equal opportunity so i think that
was very assumptive on him to say that
you should be with a 50 year old white
man like i don't know
the audacity
the audacity
so
on top of that
ally was trending on twitter last week
which by the way guys you should go
subscribe to her channel um if you want
some common sense dating advice and to
see that not all women are insane you
should go subscribe to the real femme
sapien uh but
um so i did a video guys
and i basically i'm sure you guys have
seen clips on the channel i posted it a
million times i
i said to ali i said show me your ring
and then she showed me her ring and
she
talked about how to get a high value man
and how to become a housewife
and how much she loved her husband and
apparently this set the internet in a
muck
in chaos
so ally
let's let's read some of your comments
section
do you have the the twitter thread
pulled up
i can't pull it up now if you want to go
to my youtube comment section i mean
that's fairly easy people hate me every
day over there it's like the the new
hotness is to tell me everything that's
wrong with me
i can i'll tell you this last comment
this one was pretty good
so this one says
that because people have such a problem
with my age gap all the time all the
time
so this one says i'm sorry but any woman
out here marrying a male old enough to
be her dad has daddy issues or highly
undesirable men her age or just a little
older by the way most men my age aren't
desirable i'm not trying to be mean but
you know i don't i've been through a
couple of things number one number two
it's like people care about my age gap
now so i'm 27 my husband is 50. but when
i'm 50 and he's 73 is anybody really
gonna care is anybody really gonna care
and then i'd like to go through these
scenarios in my mind like what
what would it be that people would stop
over analyzing my marriage right like
maybe if he was my age but even then
they would still have something to say
because they always have something to
say about kevin samuels too he was
divorced twice they would be like oh
like what would he know and i'm like
well i mean
more more than single people i think he
knew more than them so that has been the
audacity this week is just every day i
wake up he's an old white man i'm like
what the audacity what are the audacity
what if he was an old black man would it
be different would it be different i
don't think so i don't think so pearl
because if my husband was an older black
man they would just say i was stealing
him from the culture
i can't make these people happy
oh my god i'm going to tell you
something that happened to me today i
was doing interviews right i was doing
public interviews
and
i i'm interviewing these ladies all day
and oh my gosh my if you see the exhaust
on my face it's because this was
exhausting oh my god there's so many of
the audacities but in the end i finished
filming right and i'm like okay we got
some good footage
uh cameras are dying so i'm i'm ready to
go home this girl is like did you see my
sign that i had oh yeah i was like yeah
i did i did for the viewers i would show
it to you but i left it in my producer's
car but i had a big sign that said
feminism is a hate group and i put it
down
and i wanted people to come
and
basically disagree with me you know i'm
all for some productive conversation but
at this point i'm done and this woman is
like what does your sign say i'm like
are you
are you blind like it's in bright red
and just asking you to provoke
yeah and i'm just like oh yeah and i
just kept telling her i'm leaving and
she's like and one i'm like where was
this courage when i when i had the
cameras on she was there for a while she
was lurking so i'm like where where is
this courage where is it becky and
and so she's like following me out and
i'm like i'm done like i don't argue for
free
like i swear to god i will not i get
paid to argue now that means i'm good at
it you should pay me to argue with you
like you should give me money
to argue with you
i have a question so was this a white
feminist
um she was either white or like
mixed with something i don't know she
could have been mixed i wonder here's my
thing right because i think feminism in
the west you know i think white women
built it do you get like what's the
anger you get from your fellow
sisterhood
oh my god we're going to refer to white
women as the sisterhood now
they can't be happy with you i at least
get to get away with a lot more things
because like most latinos don't pay any
mind to feminism
you know
well they always bring up race when i'm
talking about gender
that's what irritates me
is
so whenever whenever i'm beating someone
in an argument and we're talking about
gender
then they come back and are like well
you're a white woman i'm like what the
we're talking about gender
we're talking about gender
and then it's always oh it's always oh
that's not everyone's experience and i'm
like
okay but do you have any data
facts
statistics for yours and then today this
girl was like where'd you get your data
and i didn't know off the top of my head
but i knew where i got it i just
couldn't remember the name and i
literally just pull it up on my phone
and she's like well since you don't
believe all women should i not believe
you and i was just like
i was just like i was like i mean
you can not i don't care but
no these these leftists they have the
worst logic check this out so today on
instagram i dropped
i reposted one of my shorts and then
underneath the short
and the basically
i i'm talking about why women need men
right and so underneath it somebody and
they think that they're really smart for
saying this too that's like that's the
hilarious part they're like
wonder how lesbian couples and countries
with actual parental leave factor into
this so i'm talking about why women need
to vet men's social status and that it's
easy and then this idiot this leftist
comes out like well what about the
lesbians like nobody's talking about
them that's not my platform
that's what they do
that's what they do oh my god
today
we're talking about abortion because i'm
like what i ask everyone i'm like
feminism is a hate movement and i said
so what what are we fighting for and
they're like abortion i'm like or you
could just be selective and who you
sleep with and then what what do they
always say
don't use the actual word
what about what oh what about epar
yeah what about epar
and and i'm like okay that's one percent
and then they're saying okay well
not all epars go reported and i'm like
where is your data for that
and and then they're like well i have a
friend and i'm like
well why would i just believe your
friend i don't know your friend
so that's what i like
i no i'm serious i don't know her
no no i get it i get it i'll give it to
them though because you know i think
there are people that have been essayed
and it happened so young that they
wouldn't have any recollection of it
like i'll give them that but it always
comes up with the termination of
pregnancy conversation and it's like if
you ever actually looked at the numbers
like but they but they don't care they
don't care so i wonder if it might be a
better counter position if we said hey
you know we just care about women so
much that we even care about them when
they're in the womb but then that kind
of leaves the male fetuses out of the
equation so i just i don't really know
where to find common ground with these
people i i may never i may never
no and then and then no then they'll say
i did like ten of these today
oh it's a fetus
it's not a baby and i'm like okay so
when when
like when
is it does it become a baby and not a
fetus should you be able to get an
abortion two days before you're gonna
give birth this this girl says yes
yeah i'm like
and then oh my god it was like jumping
through hoops i'm like okay girl
so and then she's like well you're
looking for an exception rather than the
rolex i always say that right and i said
i'm not looking for an exception i asked
you
when you thought
abortion should be legalized
i you had the option you could have said
three months six like
i i gave you that so
this isn't an exception this is based on
what
you said
oh my gosh and then this other girl said
believe all women and then later was
trying to say that she didn't say that
and i'm like i have this on camera wait
like in real time like how when coco
said she didn't say just a housewife but
she said it five times
maybe three okay
and then she kept saying it like after
women will do that though women will do
that they'll say something and then a
couple sentences later and say that
they've never said it
do you do guys do it too i don't know
i've only had it happen with liberal men
that i've debated
oh my gosh there was this and these
these beta males kept walking past my
camera
i told my producer to tell them to like
stop or like get in there i don't
but they kept like if my camera was like
say my camera's here and i'm back here
filming these guys kept walking in front
of it to like ruin the stream i'm like
what are you 12
oh really yeah i didn't know it was
intentional because like i was focused
on the
on the like content you know what i mean
but yeah of course but my my producer
tells me after that it was like they
were like sending people to walk i'm
like are you crazy and you won't sit
down
that's see and that's that's the problem
for me right you know what actually
matter of fact the audacity the audacity
the audacity of this feminist okay so
i've been
mildly sparring with a fellow youtuber
for quite some time very small time
youtuber
happens to be feminist but then says
like they are not really feminist but
then all they ever do is talk about
feminism how much they don't trust men
whatever so
in
in the past i've offered this person
compensation to have a conversation i
probably still have the email somewhere
i explicitly stated conversation
not debate i don't know they never
replied to me it they easily could have
made some money like my problem with
feminists is that they don't have the
confidence to come out and defend their
points it's like all they can do is show
up at protests with pink
pink kitty cat hats that's like all
they're good for so
you know whatever
ellie that's offensive they have their
tits out too
[Applause]
solid they always get naked so they end
up moving into you know i shoot her an
email on the side because i see she's
got a good work ethic i'm like you want
to spin feminist propaganda fine but let
me at least help you through these
youtube streets i even put my phone
number in there i said please don't leak
this just to extend the olive branch but
it's like these chicks are paranoid so
what ends up happening is that she
decides to react to our tick tocks right
the tick tocks where i went viral right
and all she does is go like point by
appointment point this a problem that's
a problem everybody just keeps getting
all my behind about submission like they
act like i'm gonna be submissive in any
circumstance i promise ask my husband
like there's times i haven't been
submissive like people don't people
don't always agree in a marriage okay so
i end up you know asking my audience
should i respond
to the reaction that this person spent
three hours three hours streaming
and then they told me yes she goes on to
have this impromptu livestream where
she's like well you know i don't really
think she needs to respond to it because
i feel like there isn't anything else to
talk about like if you felt that way you
shouldn't have reacted to it how many
times have you as a content creator the
audacity
have you ever wanted to react to
something but you were like nah like i
don't want the smoke i don't want this
exposure and ah like just pass guys just
do it i don't put a lot of thought i
just do i just do am i gonna thought
yeah
i probably should i should think more
but i just do it
if i feel like my god i'm like i gotta
say something
oh well there's people that i wouldn't
react to like pretty much anybody from
uh what is it um i'll call it 41 studios
wink wink i wouldn't react to anybody
from there because i just like that's a
lot that's too many problems for me like
i'm good i'm good and you know the the
audacity of these content creators they
always try to sue somebody who are you
gonna sue
for what money they know how much we
make on youtube it's not that much i
don't know pearl
anyway so i'll be reacting to her live
stream tomorrow at noon since she had
the audacity the odd okay what
what is the worst comment
have you ever had a comment that like
hurt your feelings so you were thinking
about for like days or like the audacity
well so the comments don't normally hurt
my feelings what what is
still the cognitive issue for me is when
you'll tell somebody i think women
should get married and they're like you
think women should be slaves not like
how you got from point a to point z like
i was trying to go to b
you're all the way over there i don't
understand
but i want to say i guess maybe the
rudest slash funniest comment i've ever
gotten was lady in the streets colonized
in the sheets like that was a lot
oh that's funny
um no okay
i don't even
they used to call me a four a lot but
ever since i started
i don't know they've they've kind of
laid off my looks lately i think the
better my content's gotten i don't know
why
oh yeah you know yeah
i get more positive comments when i get
hate comments for real
yeah no i do i know on youtube not on
tick tock
i want to see what on tick tock oh my
gosh actually
can i screen share i haven't used stream
labs in a while
a streamlabs or stream yard stream yard
sorry yeah you can share a tab that's
what i thought you were gonna do you
should just go to youtube video open up
the comments kapow
i can't share my screen all i can do is
like share links in the chat probably
no i wanna some beta male told me he was
really disappointed in me in a video on
tick tock
i was like i was like
ally and i should react hold on hold on
let me find it yeah what are they
they're always so weird like i'm
concerned i'm concerned
what answer is the other day go ahead
oh here we go
no you said the
oh god oh god okay sorry the video
i'm gonna share this
share screen
and i'm like you're a grown ass man like
how are you how are you this
disappointed in me
okay so this is his tick tock okay
have you seen him no i haven't seen him
it's just like
i'm like i'm probably
i'm probably giving him more views than
this
this evening expect all men on social
media sorry
can you see this
yeah i can see can you hear it can you
hear it
oh wait
okay no you can check the volume on the
tick tock itself first
wait could you hear that or no
no
oh really
have nothing select an option to share
your audio i think
oh okay sorry guys this is a struggle
stream well while while you do that
somebody asked a question with a super
chat so
well actually two questions info vader
with the 10 super chat thank you says
idea to do a pre-game show of feminists
to debate
the lunacy interesting if we could
recruit them feminists don't show up
they might do it for cash though
okay and then we have
willa with a ten dollar super chat
saying at real feminist sapien please
help me how to make my wife
be more feminine in a positive way
clothes wait to talk be more delicate
you know a lot of the times i get that
comment i i wonder about and this is
like not a dog on him or any or anything
like that but a lot of men want women to
be feminine for them without being
masculine or they could have gone
through several conflicts in a marriage
or the guy could have been regressing
not handling his responsibilities and
it's like well of course like you're
just
you're just slowly like siphoning away
your wife's femininity so you should see
about taking more leadership in the
household to see if she'll let you and
then actually perform right because at
some point results do matter and not to
pressure men insanely or anything like
that but that that i've noticed because
either the more masculine a man is the
more you just want to be feminine like
you want to be girly you want to make
him breakfast you want to look pretty
but if you're coming home to a lump on a
log it's kind of hard to want to be a
better woman for that but i will say
like modern women wouldn't you know
that's just tough in general to convince
them that it's worth worth it
ally do you know what you i seriously
have never figured out how to do the
screen share on stream labs i always do
it and um stream yards
yeah because i have
yeah you do you do what
i just share tab
let me see maybe i can share
share screen to you oh i can
cool
let's see if it lets me
okay
yeah on the private chat send me the
link to that guy okay yeah
and you have to take this one oh my gosh
i love it when people say they're so
disappointed in me because i'm like you
must have a lot going on because i like
can't be that disappointed with someone
i don't know
also i think the same thing like a lot
of these guys were talking about high
value men they'd be in the comment
section i'm like sir high value men work
60 hours a week um they can't
it can't quite be in the comments i know
people don't want to believe this
okay can you see
uh i can see it yeah i added it to the
screen
can you hear
let's see not
look at divorce as a failure i don't
know why you wouldn't yeah you chose
poorly and now you're going to be honest
the first time i saw this video about a
week ago it triggered me but i've had a
few days to think about it and here's my
thoughts divorce can mean a lot of
things to a lot of people everyone's
situation is different if you went in
recklessly in a marriage and after six
months to a year you divorced without
even trying to make it work that's a
failure in my opinion but that doesn't
speak for everybody what about the
others who are married 10 15 20 30 years
and for years prior to making that
choice they tried they worked on it they
went to counseling they went to therapy
they tried their best and gave all their
hearts to make it work or what about the
men and women who are in abusive
relationships both emotional and
physical they are in that space for
years and finally get the courage to
leave you see in those circumstances
divorce is a choice to end their
suffering and improve their lives
that's not a failure in my opinion the
true failure is staying in those
situations because in the end you failed
yourself
now look at the comments wait look look
at the comments in the comments because
i don't know i'm going to show you i
want to show you
no i want to show you look at that's
what i said so
go go down go down circumstance 1 they
tried and failed circumstance two you
failed at picking a good partner
circum when people don't have a good
argument they look for exceptions to the
rule the average marriage is seven to
eight years keep going down
and then
a few more
um and then go
to his page he did another video after
this it's right after this one pearl
you've been messing with this man
ma'am
why
well i was just like
you're arguing like a woman sir
but they don't know that they're arguing
like a woman i think we've trained
men to you know ignore their logical
side of things
i think this is okay no i found it i
can't see your screen anymore no i'm
getting it right now okay
welcome to the struggle stream yeah the
first time we're doing this it'll be
thank you
can you keep for those two dollar super
chat social and 500 people in here
is it really yeah 500 people in the chat
um real from oh you answered this
question okay i think that's all right
guys thank you for the new memberships
we're gonna um jess i just put just in
charge of membership so she's gonna have
behind the scenes footage um that you
guys can see so you can see like what a
day looks like on like a um
a show day and what else we do behind
the scenes and thank you for the ten
dollar super chat shale1997 shout out to
both of you keep up the good work of
free thinking and how women should be
okay let's see the next video
we're gonna do
i'm sorry you know this is like what
bothers me
and i don't i really don't want to do ad
hominems i don't want to roast him but
this is like a man in his early 40s who
i presume is single in a graphic tee
like
ah
it's just not the same
it's not wait share the scoop to show
the screen i can't see it oh shoot i
have to add it to the stream hold on
okay now go damn
now i have to start over i'm sorry i'm
sorry struggle stream
i know this won't mean anything to you
but i'm actually disappointed i didn't
respond because i've been following you
for quite some time and i don't agree
with all your takes but i respect them
that's why i followed you thank you and
i'm very disappointed in your response
because you cannot with the following
you have you have to be more responsible
than this no i don't
i hate i hate that argument i hate that
argument because there's people that
have youtube channels with a million
followers
like you can't control all the crazy
people in your comments section like if
we could control them
pearl and i wouldn't get emails about
being sister-wise sister-wise
we can't do anything about it it's the
internet just how you found her video
somebody else out there who needs to be
in therapy also found her video we can't
control that they're all also they're
acting like
okay so
like women don't even normally lose in a
divorce i
uh okay fine
you cannot preach to your following that
everybody who has had a divorce is a
failure yes i can you're no better than
those bro podcasts who are calling
single mothers low-hanging fruit and
horse you see i call them you can't
connectively define a demographic
you should know that
very disappointed i know this won't mean
anything
you know what
he virtue signaled he tried to make
himself look good by making you look bad
oh that's not sexy that's weird why
would he do that i was
i was like laughing when i saw it
because
he he's he's acting like
trisha paytas has millions of followers
do you know who that is
yeah and she's unethical chrissy teigen
no followers told a 16 year old to start
a gun
yeah it means it means nothing like i
don't want to say nothing it means
you're good at creating entertaining
content but it sure as hell doesn't mean
like
that that i i owe you an explanation for
my content but congrats sir you got a
reaction video because i had this show
today so
there you go
i don't understand so here's here's like
the the thing about it right we've
talked about this before like divorce
reas really
financially is typically not an l for
women also for the women whose husbands
file
us knowing everything we know about men
and talking to men daily like i find
that
i find that a little bit suspicious
sometimes like a man has to be driven to
the point of no return in order to file
and then so it's not actually a loss for
the woman in that way right but when we
recommend for women to stay
it's because
like a lot of us are going to live to be
90
you know and is the argument that you're
getting into with your spouse in your
late 20s worth being alone when you're
70 80 90 years old like we're forward
thinking out there and it happens all
the time i i can get into a disagreement
with my husband and then automatically
he's the bad guy to most people right a
lot of people naturally would take your
side as a woman and it gets you confused
as a woman like you'd be looking at men
like oh like they're all problematic
like ah
it's it's not good and divorce is an l
like i'm divorced that was by definition
and l did i have a come up after the
fact sure
but it was still an l it was still it's
never a w unless you're a gold digger
yeah and and on top of that like who
says i want to be divorced and i i
didn't say that their whole life was a
failure but that marriage was absolutely
a failure
if you got divorced like it's not a
success
like an indicator of success is like
continuing to be married
that's the indicator what's the even
will smith came out and said that his
first divorce was a failure to him now
he ended up with jada so i don't think
he learned anything but that's actually
who he left his first wife for
looking silly right now
the audacity the audacity
and um
on top of that
he he brings up the exception exception
to the rule and i just it drives me nuts
because we don't talk about the role we
keep talking about the exceptions to the
rule
and i never said that all all divorces
like nobody needs to get divorced i'm
just saying either you're not good at
picking
so you get better at picking men or
women
or maybe you're the problem like i don't
know figure it out but if you go out and
say i did nothing wrong like how are you
gonna improve in the future
that and you know that's the thing too
is like a lot of women who are divorced
they really don't want to say what they
did wrong that's only that's probably
the only reason why people majority of
the time are okay with me getting
divorced is because i'm like
like i sucked too
i was not good at that objectively i
sucked i sucked so
if he ever watches his content sorry man
my bad my back
whoops
[Laughter]
no we all overcome they'll get over it
oh my goodness it's just
the the shaming
because you would dare to say something
that goes against what makes people feel
good right but i you know i think people
forget that we want what's helpful for
women in the long term
i just don't like lying to women that's
that's about that's like what bothers me
is we have these older feminists that
made poor choices in their youth and
instead of saying
hey these were poor choices this is how
you can improve and do better than me
they try to like bring down the young
women with them
and make excuses for their bad behavior
and then they shame men
into liking them
and call it a stigma like oh there
shouldn't be a stigma around divorce
like
you're divorced i i think you would
agree there should be a stigma around
divorce
yeah there should be a stigma but you
know what so
oh my gosh like here marriage is hard
relationships are hard romance is hard
the f'ed up thing about it was when i
wanted to get divorced the first thought
in my mind was what are people gonna say
about me not like oh i'm gonna lose this
guy but you know that's what happens
when you choose somebody that's
incompatible but there should be a
stigma because there are stupid reasons
to to get divorced like i find myself
you know when i get into little tips
with my husband i share some of this
information with other people they're
like
you know shouldn't you set boundaries
like
should you leave like no i would sooner
sleep in another bed in the same house
like i sometimes it doesn't make sense
to leave sometimes like i don't i don't
understand the grass is not greener it's
not greener i don't know
rebecca and james they say the same
thing he was like well if if i get tired
of her she'd get her a little something
but i i'm not going nowhere we stayed in
this house together say this house
together people just don't get it that's
what the older generation used to have
like even i i think our grandparents
they used to separate but they would
never divorce
and they would just take they would just
take the l and do it for the kids but
you know
i i think it's one thing getting
divorced when
you have
like it's just you
but then once you have children it's
just not about you anymore and parents
don't want to hear that because a lot of
them made a selfish decision in the
moment especially women that they come
to regret later
and they don't they don't they don't
want to hear that
that's what kevin samuels was good at
was like some of these women would be
like well i got tired of the father of
my kids and i left and blah blah blah
he's like okay
do you have more money before or after
and they're like
before okay was a father in the home
before or after
they're like
before and it's like it's like a net
loss for for women oftentimes when they
get divorced okay so she gets divorced
she goes out there in the dating market
like what if she can't actually find
someone because sometimes the problem
is you as the woman and you end up
marrying another dude that's like the
same guy just different shoes different
face same dude
and that's the thing i think the older
you get the more people realize you
can't run from yourself
don't scare me
no
no i mean i mean like if you go from
relation a lot of people go from
relationship to relationship to
relationship and realize they have the
same issue i mean this is something like
i i've come across at times where i'm
like [ __ ] i had this issue and this
issue in two different relationships so
maybe maybe it's maybe it's me
you know if you have you can't you can't
run from you
and you see it with your your exes too
because they they go through the same
patterns but with different people
like you can't you can't run from
yourself
yeah i mean you can try to all you want
but you can't no even now oh my gosh
like look like my marriage is not
perfect i have issues i i have things
that i have to work for
you're gonna be working through your own
ish for the rest of your
life whether you're single or not
i just don't want to be alone sorting
through my own ish at 60. no thank you
shoot i'd rather have a better like i'd
rather talk about companionship like at
that point i'd rather have companionship
to be alone but i'd rather i'd rather
love a masculine man don't get me wrong
like first choice first choice but at 60
like come on man just hang out on the
couch let me cry a little bit watch the
netflix just come on
uh we got some super chats i'm going to
read let's see
um
ally please speak on sex starve
marriages and cheating oh the audacity
well it's the audacity and then it's not
so it's only the audacity because a lot
of women that complain about like their
man isn't manly enough for them to want
to sleep with like sometimes they'd be
looking like whales okay like that's
that's my problem because i i get it i
get it the betatization through a
thousand concessions or you know you're
a man done fell off the wagon a little
bit you know maybe it's getting a little
bit chubby but you as the woman you
gotta look at what your role is was or
is in feminizing that man did he used to
go to the gym and then you wanted more
of his attention so you you asked him to
stop right because there's things a man
can take away like you can't really take
away going to work but you can take away
going to the gym right you keep
bothering him you don't want him hanging
out with other people okay well he ends
up staying home it's like it's not fair
for women to complain about how
unattractive their husbands are if
they're the ones that were behind the
feminization process
at the same time it is like you're
looking at the man why why would you let
her do that where's your self-respect so
i it's a problem on both sides but what
i think
is wrong right is um the man will still
pay the bills and have the same
responsibilities even if his wife is
sleeping with him or not and men
actually need that and you'll read so i
read a book called the proper hearing
feeding of husbands some women if you
talk to them you're like do you want to
have sex with your husband like ah nah
really i'm like okay but once you guys
start do you want to have sex with your
husband and they're like yeah actually
yeah and it's like okay well so you need
you need to put a little grace in there
you know what i mean put a little bit of
work a little bit of work it's okay
yeah and i i people got so mad at me
because i said that sex is the duty
like
especially he's paying the bills for you
if he's paying the bills for you i'm
like
it's free rent
i'm thinking about how long it would
take me to work to pay those bills i
could
like
i'm just saying it
i think to an extent it is a duty
because i think
it's a violation of vows to withhold sex
from your husband that's my perspective
because you know like if you want to
take the christian perspective but in
general i think it's a violation of vows
because if you aren't having sex with
your husband
what are you leaving him to because
she's going to complain about it anyway
she's going to end up complaining you're
leaving him to prawn or he might step
out of the marriage then you'll complain
a lot or you're sequestering him to
self-pleasure for the rest of his life
or the rest of the marriage like that
seems unethical to me right and it's
just like
i think i think the problem is that
women are marrying men that they're not
attracted to or
you know the the guy gets comfortable
right and so he gets fat on his own but
then it's like also the wife though like
sis did you try to stay sexy for him so
he's the only one that got to stay sexy
nobody else
yeah those are my thoughts
okay zach magnani says y'all are the
most based women born between 1992 and
1998 y'all's content is helping me build
a good thing with my girl i'm glad i
spent long enough ignoring my own human
nature to please idiots i don't even
like
um five dollars from chv the audacity
thank you thank you
um five dollars from something to watch
is it true that the average women are
more humble and less likely to to
divorce
that's a good question um average women
what it was so what's the question like
average in looks
versus like above average and looks i
think women just file most of the
divorces though i mean that's
all we know
yeah and every time i've seen a man file
a divorce and then i heard his side of
the story i'm like oh
my god like that was a lot i'm telling
every time every time y'all if you guys
are watching
so for your divorced guy friends out
there
talk to the ones that filed and find out
why because it'd be horrendous on the
flip side whenever i ask a woman why she
filed i mean it's it's really not
egregious it's typical stuff like still
reasons that i would file you know but
it's just it's not the same intensity or
severity it's not
yeah the guys the girls are like yeah i
wasn't feeling it and the guys are like
yeah she was abusing me for two years
and
um okay rishi
rama ram i'm i'm sorry but thank you for
50 super chat love the positive messages
around marriage femininity and children
thank you guys for these super chats
it's going towards um the pregame show
podcast that i have um i want to get
another camera and
yeah so hopefully i can get one next
month with all this super chat so i
appreciate you guys
um matt butcher um the common sentiment
i hear from divorced men is they feel
like they failed
well they might have like
something failed they either aren't good
at picking women and they don't
understand women's true nature
or
you know maybe they were the problem i
don't know
i i had a conversation with my
ex-husband i was like what happened
because i did everything that i could do
and god at this point i hate talking
about it but i'm just so tired of people
acting like oh my gosh like how could
this have a cr
like you don't know until you try like
why don't you get married and find out
and report back to us i asked i was like
why did this happen i will say he had
accountability
about that he he regressed he let some
things go and that was pretty much it so
it was good to hear
on his part too that it wasn't just like
something that i did you know
which is
like
hopefully
people that do end up get getting
divorced they do have an after action
review and ask one another what went
down so that they can learn for the next
time around but oh man like it's just
it's just plain hard i think
to pick good
i think that's the harder problem do you
think it's harder to pick someone good
or to stay with someone
wow i mean i've never been married so
i think that's a hard question for me to
answer
um for me it's been
harder
um
i would say harder to like find someone
that i feel like i have the same values
as and is also masculine in my age group
um
i would say has been harder for me
but
i don't know that's a good question
really i think it's harder to pick good
you think it's harder to pick good
yeah and i think it's harder to pick a
man that you're attracted to
but um you know what i'll say
like i hear so much about modern women
don't get me wrong but modern men too
like destiny rough the audacity the
audacity so i
today i profile the single on my
instagram if you guys want to see her go
see her she seems like a nice gal she
follows my content
i have men that are dming me trying to
get in contact with her when i tagged
her and they're like oh but her profile
is private i'm like well then you
request her like there are men that they
want you to hold their hand while they
go find women like no how are you back
to
the men like that need mothers like they
just want to be babied
oh my gosh that that is there is a
subset of men like this
that it's like when we were at the
conference oh my god the audacity
ally tell this story tell them what
happened at the masculine
excellence conference
we still okay this was
this was an incident we pearl and i
still don't know why this happened
we
were
going to a restaurant i was trying to go
to a restaurant with my friends but for
some reason everybody's like we are all
gonna go to the restaurant i was like
okay
like that's totally cool fine so pearl
and i start walking
and it's like people were asking me and
they were uh wanting me to take charge
right and i'm a woman and i'm not saying
that it was my place like i'm happy to
lead us to a restaurant that wasn't
the particular issue although it is
uncomfortable being a woman like leading
35 men so pearl and i pull off to the
side to do something for tick tock and
we were like trying to tell them like
hey no no just just like just go like
we're going to do something for tick
tock just go just go and it's like they
couldn't assume authority and that's a
problem with modern men y'all don't
assume authority for nothing
nothing
and it's like why
to typically from what i could see on a
college campus it's white nighting for a
woman to use cuttlefish game to get to
her i'm like this is not helpful that's
not helpful and they were like standing
there asking us a million questions and
i'm like guys just go to the restaurant
like what we're at the masculine
excellence conference go be masculine
you know what also is annoying all these
guests now that my channel's blowing up
all these guests i have been chasing
down for months trying to get on my
channel no they want to come on
yeah the audacity the audacity i would
say like there is some sexism you know
if you're for some reason if you're a
successful woman and you talk to other
men who you know your co-workers or your
peers but you've got reasonable talent
like no joke reasonable talent i think
pearl's reasonable talent people think i
have reasonable talent you tell these
guys constructive criticism constructive
feedback it's like it doesn't register
but then if a man says it that they're
like oh okay cool like typically when i
give men constructive feedback they
start debating with me and i'm like
then why'd you ask why why did you ask
why did you ask like i was happy to keep
it to my damn self right i want to keep
the secrets for me
but but honestly the more masculine the
bad i think they're more likely to take
advice from people that know what like
like wait like they won't do that it's
always like the beta men that do that
like that you know i mean like i found
that the more alpha the guy the more
likely
he is to like like because for me
if i feel like the guy actually is more
alpha like he's more secure and so he
he's not going to be bad about in asking
a girl to talk about something that i'm
competent at
yeah yeah i would agree i would agree it
comes yeah it does come down to
masculine masculinity and it's like
alpha for sure is a mindset that's the
weird thing about uh about beta meals
it's like
it's it's a prison that they made in
their own mind all you got to do is
believe you can and get after it like
that's
that's literally it pearl's an
entrepreneur i'm an entrepreneur when i
found out that i could just do things i
was like what the whole time nobody told
me yeah i built the show in three months
it's just kind of nuts i feel like
i lost enough sleep for a lifetime but
okay johnny vo i grew up without a
mother or father but this was not enough
of an excuse for me men and women both
use crutches to learn self-improvements
christine christian reni it is it easier
for the average woman to find a man than
the average man to find a woman normally
i'd say it's easier for the average
woman to find a man but it's harder for
the average woman to find a man the man
that she wants
and i would say it's easier for the
average man to find a woman but it's
harder for the average man to find a
woman that like actually wants him
agree agree did you see the 50 super
chat from rishi did we do that yeah
yeah i did that one i just wanted to
make sure it was pink
yeah yeah
um johnny arbor there are a lot of
selfish people in the world twice
divorced single for the last 12 years
have not dated in two years no good
women in their 40s happy with my dogs
older you get the harder it is to find
someone i think that's true actually
because i think the older we get the
more we're all set in our way is sort of
oh yeah oh i agree well
we're more set in our ways too but like
sometimes like i've been saying if i
have to end up with a con in a conflict
with my husband people were like have
you thought about leaving i'm like
you want me to go back out in the dating
market at 28 as a twice divorced woman
who's like what man
what man would choose that i'm not
trying to be mean i'm not trying to be
like i think i'm a great person
but that's that's a lot that's i
wouldn't marry me either oh what i'm
supposed to go out there for tripping
pearl tripping
you'd still find someone
i'm not i'm not telling you to do that
but i'm just like
there's
i just don't understand why i can't
share minor conflicts without people
being like have you considered leaving
i'm like why did i even talk to you why
did i
no i know
adrian what what do you think of beta
male is how would you describe it
they're they're in a prison of their own
mind right so it's like
anyone that makes excuses for the state
that they're in instead of having
accountability there's just some there i
know a lot of beta men and you know they
come to me for advice and i mean even
personally like these are men that i've
met in real life they come to me for
advice and
i just don't want to start running their
mouth and not nothing's going to change
they're not going to put anything into
action and
they
the thing about it is is that they're
always shocked about it too
like they keep doing the same thing they
get the same results and they're still
confused but they won't have the
gumption to pivot
so i mean that's what i would say is any
man who is limiting his own abilities
through the constructs in his mind
wow that's not
i would just say it's like the men
that don't know how to lead at all and
don't make choices to like
change their lives you know what i mean
i don't know it's hard it's hard to
explain it but as a woman like we'd know
it we could feel the beta
as soon as like a beta guy comes up we
we feel it it grosses us out we hate
betas
oh yeah i don't even like them as
co-workers they'd be the type of dudes
to throw you under the bus as a female
co-worker and you're like that's two
brute
h2 why would you do this to me the
audacity the audacity
i am a five foot four woman you're gonna
start a rumor in the office about me for
what sir or why
why
i'm trying to think of the weird ass oh
my gosh or random people people this is
the audacity random people will message
me asking me
to interview them they have like a
thousand followers
for you to interview them i haven't had
that happen yet on my channel a lot of
collabs yeah a lot of collab requests i
just ignore it because i
i don't
pearl and i worked hard to get here and
not to be mean but
i don't think donovan typically
interviews women that don't try right i
think that's like randomly how he got on
his platform you know so i would say
he's like a decent judge of a good
worker or other people that we've
collabed with if pearl and i's video
sucked even though we had low subs
people wouldn't work with us but they
didn't suck they were good and you have
the control as the content creator to
put out a good product it took me a
while to figure out but i did
yeah and i knew when i met you i won i
knew we were gonna be besties and two
and two um
i it's funny because i didn't respond to
your first email to me but i knew i was
going to i just was oh my god i was so
stressed out that but
but i was like i knew we were gonna be
friends and i knew that you were gonna
like pop off one of these days because
you're talented and the stuff you say is
true
and you're not afraid to call out women
on their bs
because women again and again and again
will have an excuse for god damn
everything and you don't put up with
that
no no i mean in fact i think i'm
probably too honest online about some of
the things that i've been through but
it's important for women to see another
woman take accountability and you don't
die like i don't burst into flames for
saying some of the mistakes that i've
made and you learn from them and you
grow and it's like the more mistakes you
confess to
and you learn from as a woman it
improves your status in the dating
market if you do the work behind your
revelations the things that you find out
i'm like i think more women should be
held accountable like pearl you know
what you hurt my feelings did you know
that
do you know you hurt my mind did i why
we already talked about this you told me
i was talkative and that's why i'm not
friends
[Applause]
what the that's the same reason i don't
have friends we'd be talking like
yeah but i didn't know that i i thought
everyone was talkative but you were like
no actually it's a personality thing and
like sometimes sometimes people like us
don't know when to stop talking that was
not a fun thing to hear but it was
important it was important
yeah
well the thing is though about the
talkers we all find each other
yeah i thought it was normal because
they went to the conference and everyone
was talking and you were like no that's
not how that goes
no that's a youtuber thing like
youtubers can just we all it's it's
weird though because when you get in a
room with youtubers
like it's like everyone is just going
no it's fun though okay um
let's see let's see there's three more
super chats so
um j rag sole fiesta wow this chip oh
wait i did this one um uh johnny arbor
double oh seven alpha runs towards
trouble to fixes betas are lying cowards
or a combat bat i've seen it btw's
most alphas aren't pretty boys oh that's
a really good that's a really good way
to that is a good point i would say that
but i like the blue collar rugged dudes
i like like we need to bring those dudes
back you know because i think
sometimes
some men they start making so much money
they lose a little bit of their
masculinity because they can't fix
anything in their house right all they
can do is hire someone right so it's
like like sometimes sometimes the
plumber the carpenter the electrician
like those dudes are hot
those dudes are hot
hvac technician yes baby i got a fridge
i got a thing for construction workers i
don't know what it is
um
ally this is a good question for you
would it be wiser for a virgin to
withhold sex until marriage or to have
sex with a seemingly committed
relationship
would it be better
yeah like should she wait till she's
married or should she have sex with her
like boyfriend
so
[Music]
i'm gonna say that she should wait until
she's married but only because of this
well if a guy likes you whether you
sleep with him or not and again this is
unpopular to hear in the manosphere
whether you sleep with him or not he's
gonna be there right so if if you as a
woman are showing your character and you
are most likely religious because i i
don't if you don't like view marriage
religiously and you just do it as a
contract with the state that sort of
lends what it makes sense but if you're
a religious woman
you are active in the faith and he can
see that and witness that he's probably
just going to propose to you and you
guys are probably just going to get
married right like i don't i don't see
the point in you know
modifying that belief set that that's
not to say that i did it right but you
know shameless plug i will be
interviewing an actual trad con who did
save yourself for marriage on my
platform soon so yeah i mean that's just
that's what i think
yeah i agree with that um
fudge knuckle autism exaggerates issues
with eye contact obsessions and lack of
self self-care it has skyrocketed
rocketed since the 70s were chemically
castrating boys
um richard hernandez i used to think it
was a little weird to pay to comment but
now i see the importance of supporting
content creators you like yeah no guys i
would not have been able to make this
show happen without
uh some serious super chats i literally
it was almost like i was so broke a
couple months ago and you guys literally
like gave me 500 in super chats to buy a
sound board that
literally like launched my show so yeah
sending super chats is so helpful and
it's like vital in order to upgrade the
equipment so i really appreciate all the
super chats even the small ones like i
know a lot of people watch for free so
when you guys send send them i
appreciate it anyways um
the
ten dollar super chat
from kieran alex new to your channel and
i've witnessed and enjoyed your red pill
live attempts on feminists have you ever
heard of
karen stroghan i've never heard of that
jvp is anti
is alright for anti-feminism but it's
not really his focus
yeah karen strong she's uh
a men's rights activist i believe but
she has really good reasons too and i
think she's been sexually assaulted in
the past and she's come out and said you
know hey like i don't hate men why do
you right
um but she does a really good breakdown
about how feminism is a female
empowerment movement and it's totally
misandrist and yeah i'm a fan i like her
a lot
okay
um
okay well i think i just wanted to go
for like an hour so i think i'm gonna
wrap up the show but do you have any
last final the audacity comments this is
fun we gotta do this again
oh yeah we can it'll be better next time
this is the first time we're doing it so
it's gonna take us a while to get smooth
and into the groove of things but
uh any final final comments
i don't know i mean women if you're
watching talk to men more but
probably if you want to get to know men
better don't talk to the ones that want
to sleep with you and that's going to be
everyone that's not in your family so
have honest conversations with your
brothers and your uncles and your
fathers and ask them the uncomfortable
questions about the dating market
because they're the only people they're
going to tell you
they're the only people that are gonna
tell you
or you know i suppose you could have a
male mentor whose wife is already like
super smoking hot to where like you just
can't even compete
those are some options and and men
uh you know being a woman is tough and
i'll say it because of this
it's one thing to live by logic which i
would assume most men do given their
neurobiology although you know sometimes
they don't act logically
but if you had to feel your reality
and the facts were different you'd have
a hard time navigating the world too and
that's what it is to be a woman is your
feelings it kind of dictate your entire
perception of what's going on around you
and that's tough and so yeah like we
make a lot of mistakes in the dating
work i'm not saying to allow us to dodge
accountability but i'm just saying to
empathize understand it's not fun i
don't like living confused do you like
living confused pearl do you like it no
i overthink things all the time yeah i'm
not all the time me too
oh there's three more super chats um
small sc-111 upgrades people upgrades um
ish master when you said any made king
cooker clean but only a wife can make a
home that hit me right in the feels
because i've never heard that before p.s
i'm a roofer
um
swish
i do i do like roofers
um anyways um
zhv for the appreciation
okay um thank you guys let me know in
the chat if you want this to be like a
weekly series where we talk about our
comment section
um
and the people that had the audacity
this week just to give you like a little
bit of the behind the scenes of what
goes on but you're a content creator
because there's a lot of people with the
audacity that you don't hear about
yeah no that might be good that might be
good because a lot of the times some of
my comments
they're like that title was really rude
i'm like it's the algorithm like i have
to make it rude so you'll click on it
i'm sorry i'm a nice lady so it would be
good to give them some more behind the
scenes info
yeah yeah we definitely can um
so um guys don't forget to like the
video subscribe to the channel and go
subscribe to ali's channel she has been
killing it let's get her to 20k subs she
you're at what 19 now
i think i think i'm gonna break 19 today
yeah definitely come on help her go help
her break 19 go hit that subscribe
button guys and we will talk to you next
time bye
wait hold on i got